rebounding numbers in favor of killing
[Applause]
on this first team that devastating
seven-game series long too much - in
this box what they don't get it on home
you know mom this is gonna know that was
on with the double girl women we have a
new leader coach Delilah and then the
slam dunk hardwood power laters
starting to get his rhythm and timing
down and Bryant gets denied by Kawhi
Leonard Adam out compared to his first
Finals MVP it was nearly identical this
kids the next generation of Spurs
excellence and he fires it down why he's
playful Jesus
Brett Brown has them playing at a high
level on the defensive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful crossbowmen scripted stolen
Josephina excellently pass to Leonard
and Leonard Latham yeah he's so
underrated in my mind when the we talk
about the greatest point guards in the
league where does 20 Parker's name come
up
Kawhi Leonard knocks it away second team
All NBA last year for Tony Parker
Leonard Charlie have a Marcus all lay up
to their credit
while I litter it off the takeaway jeez
got it up and under and Broadway blocked
it from behind score knocked away good
one
[Applause]
[Music]
Mozgov was great to block news cha ki
bong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now is the time to put your foot down
and get back in the gym phase with eight
points and five rebounds off the bench
and there is a flying Hawaiian centered
with the defense of Paducah if he kept
it in front of him it's a layer and then
the seven points again 74 percent from
the line he's got five times tonight
[Applause]
I pay attention we talk about all the
time you fall asleep you get cavalier in
front of Kawhi Leonard and we have seen
this running shoes I mean this is a
unbelievable display a defense by Cory
Joseph and Kawhi Leonard I tell you what
this team has not been healthy all year
and so it may look like they're just
starting to play though as you see
another steal by Linnet know they're
just starting to get healthy as he
closed it down
miss everyone who's in over Oliver
whatever reason one of eight from the
field on the two points run with the
steel two on untitled on pylons best
numbers at all categories he's got eight
points here in the first half Leonard
Leonard gets it
and on the shot clock for Durant Kawhi
Leonard an incredible block oh wow I
don't mind the market just taking that
shot there after the ball moves around
Leonard stopped Turan again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go in and out and Ronde love that one
letter Tipton's talking and this is when
you talk about taking advantage of
children here for wine Leonard taken
rondae Hollis is candy see what though
knowing Hollis Jefferson he understands
that's not gonna
well she's wonderful too late to go to
that minimal that is now 105 and Oprah
to from three payment ooting fifty
percent from behind the art a steal here
by Leonard get something and easy to
don't rest on him
four minutes to play the first this is
amazing he loses his step earlier gets
back in the play and usually you're a
little bit hesitant you're feeling he's
gonna jump over you and maybe Duncan
[Applause]
[Applause]
was beating on the perimeter he just
continues to stay in the plan - Suzi
sees that ball game only winning three
of them shot the two bags pickpocket
here comes polemical
well for a number of years he would not
have taken that shot he would have
looked and continued for location of the
ball and there he is with a block on the
other end Leonard on one end and back on
the defensive side plate by the letters
[Applause]
here comes red it is green
[Applause]
NVP to step her that's what kind of
season he have now guarding Steph Curry
comes up with the steal
hip pocket shams Leonard
if you've got the hammer you've got to
use it
arrest has it Clippers now by three
final minute bacon over running with
Athiya I told you third-highest steal
rate in the entire NBA there's money
through Aldrich or Gasol can't let her
took it away from a club or any thousand
where that's the one thing you don't
want to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's two wide leonarda's great job
playing the passing lanes just digs that
steel out back after that big day late
the other night against Memphis when
they give up 69 in the first half boy
nobody has more deflections at the
forward position and steals than Kawhi
Leonard how's miss Bogdanovich leading
the break he's trying to climb up the
charts pride today leading by 16 and a
block by maybe the best defender in the
NBA
Marco strip got a ride back nice pass
and then the
[Applause]
the clown's kicks it out fires
[Applause]
Hawaii collapsing on Monroe
[Applause]
and then coming back the opposite
direction
I didn't like that pass in the Oprah
court that Kauai through to David Lee
but he makes up for it comes back six
turnovers seven points the Spurs have
scored off those now
[Music]
[Applause]
what kind of pressures on that shot for
him as opposed to the other guys
here's Korea on the drive the boat
[Applause]
those barriers down for what that one by
a 90% free-throw shooter
three-point lead for New Orleans numbers
turn around and find the open man
letter raises up
[Applause]
exactly is done and then James Martin
picks he's got a blade that boss
destroyed off the glass
an average with the block right and I'm
not know that was gone and then there's
no rank in the piece of farm or here in
San Antonio
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but there I get in our time you got
yourself you guys to 5-footers nothing
you not hurt again
[Applause]
let's Brooke gets it back can I poke the
lower airway Leonard and Leonard able to
track it down and gets the easy to it's
a 10-point game
it's the VCU he comes in shooting now
right here you call great Grace Lee this
is why you love Leonard
what a great defense agreed that was to
a star Mills for three
playing like it in Game one with
confidence
[Applause]
[Music]
gets the ball back he stepped out of
bounds the Rockets dick wall just being
at the claw right here on the block shot
on a reason shot clock running down
great timing there if late Leonard it
was the pump bacon lost the handle he's
looking for the foul here Paul Harden
with the Euro step and we've seen that
happen a few times spacing kid and that
had to be a lot of fun for Richard
called the challenge straight Wiles met
LaMarcus Aldridge when he gets his legs
into his shot his mechanics are
excellent
diving stop by letter / play / play all
my goodness what a tremendous play did
not give up on a play chases them off
the line defense tested here now
Simmons being on the back loses head
landed with the Pope right down here's
Pascal and then you start pressing a
little bit with your office because he
as you said night he's the shot so
doctors great make night in night huh
here's bread man he gets it to go
Smith over to Pachulia John a dribble
handoff knocked away by Leonard loose
ball
[Applause]
Joonas but check this out Kawhi Leonard
getting his name in as we see so Popkin
and it's coming back up and reacting
getting the ball selfishly Winslow with
it on a handoff to why he takes it away
from Wade little defensive play see I
come right Richardson defense here Kawhi
Leonard earlier Dwyane Wade just getting
down makes himself big gets those hands
in and at the other end
pascale siaka that he didn't take those
shots before but now he takes it with
much more consistency but he still does
that on both ends of the floor
hitting the nice buck
following walks his shot on the right
side that time just blowing that play up
[Applause]
flat nerd what a denial Paris ball fake
bounces for genuine four seconds three
seconds ten when he drives in puts it up
now we go to overtime
[Applause]
so I'll write it again so you see it
just don't expect him to get it but one
of the league leaders and steals and
deflections that's why scored in the
second quarter for Kawhi Leonard with
the steal
[Applause]
coverage by Ibaka Cody dogs
breathe
into the frontcourt Maori with the
screen deadly kind of
Rosen with the rebound Spurs up by one
[Applause]
murdered
DeRozan of men :
look at the long reach of Kawhi Leonard
one star against the other trade
partners first lead since it was 63-61
here's Walker for is the help defender
look at this see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right up in the curry bhakti there to
help up curry gets passive laughs
shotlock that's been the number one talk
in sports to debate should he have
played in that game the other night
well I don't know any of the medical
stuff and I wasn't obviously that's the
Aachen gets it done Daanish Domini and
take over games offensively LeBron
arista his palmer can't believe his eyes
the Johnson in size kicks it back out
the to break shot clock is three can't
bring it down
bring the ball down here gets a street
goatee Washington Clippers match their
largest lead of the game that they
established back in the first quarter of
6:00 rush is it in love from above from
Kawhi Leonard and the Clippers lead by
eight and make baskets like he dealing
their last possessions try this way a
double-double for kawari the lead 95
bucks 10 rebounds how about another
steal sidestepping Belinelli before 1
out of 2 through Kawhi he comes away
with a steal the gift of ground elevates
and punches it into the right hand and
get it back in the Davises hands with
Beverly garland him look at that handle
but stripped by Leonard Leonard drives
inside back to Sioux box lock for the
foul the pool late in the clock
[Applause]
while in it right here you look at them
locked in on that basketball one-man
fast break nice dunk the intensity is
picking up it could be both but I'll
tell you right now 500 has long ways
away for a 22 and 33 ballclub Doc Rivers
has a timeout remaining Celtics do not
smart will inbound
[Applause]